Rabbi Joey, thank you for being on my show
20 Minute Leaders.
It's very gracious of you
to give me your time.
Thank you for inviting me.
Of course, of course,
So, we know each other from J- Ventures,
where you're also an LP.
And while J-Ventures has this
incredible mission of both investing.
Investing is part
of a capitalistic Kibbutz.
While bringing together
Jewish-Americans and Israelis,
you're approaching this issue of the
difference between the two communities,
not necessarily from a financial
and an investment route,
but more from a more cultural
and community aspect, right?
Right. In other words, I think that
the Jewish community has a lot to offer
the Israeli community and vice versa.
And I think the commonality
between both are Judaism.
Okay. So, right before we get into that,
I'd love you to give me a little bit
of background about yourself.
Where are you from and how did
you even get to Silicon Valley?
And to ask yourself the question,
how do I work with these two
communities within the Bay Area?
Okay. So, I'm originally
from Toronto, Canada.
Toronto is a very very strong
Jewish community.
Also with a very large Israeli population.
And I grew up there in day schools.
I had a very strong Jewish education.
I ended up getting a degree there
in university in political science.
And I went afterwards to go and study
to become a rabbi in Israel.
I am teached in both.
And I got my ordination
while I was in Jerusalem.
And when I was a student on campus,
I was very active
in a lot of Jewish activism.
Both on behalf of Israel
but also all sorts of other juries.
It was before the Iron Curtain fell.
I'm quite old.
And so, I was busy fighting to get
the Jews out of the Soviet Union
and Ethiopia and Syria.
And that was sort of my career
when I was in college.
I eventually became the vice president
of something called
the World Union of Jewish Students.
And from there, I decided that if I wanted
to make a real impact on the Jewish world,
the best idea would be to get
a very strong Jewish education
and be able to connect people
to their heritage.
So, I left Canada.
I went to Israel.
I was there for eight and a half years.
Wow. Studied for eight and a half years.
I did.
Wow.
And I ended up getting married
after the first six and a half.
And my wife and I,
Sorry. After the first two years,
I was there married six and a half years.
And while I was in Israel,
I was trying to figure out
what my next step would be.
And people always spoke about
the Bay Area as this anomaly.
That there is a black hole
on the Jewish map
because it was under-serviced
with respect to Jewish education.
There were very few day schools.
There were very few kids
going to day schools.
There was not much around.
And especially, within the more
traditional community,
there was very, very little.
There were a few synagogues
that were here that were tiny.
There were a couple Chabad
[--] that were here.
And so, when we looked around,
it looked like an amazing opportunity
to try to do something
in the field of Jewish education.
I ended up putting
a team together in Israel
and we all came as six families.
We moved here in 2001.
And we started it was called,
the Jewish Study Network.
And the tagline is:
To raise the level of Jewish literacy
in the Bay Area.
Now, is this for both Israelis
and American-Jewish people?
Or is this just for American Jews?
What sort of the target audience for this?
It's for both.
It's for everybody.
Okay. Wonderful.
That alludes to an interesting point,
because I think this is
a very interesting conversation.
Especially because, I'm here
living in Palo Alto.
Basically across the street
I'm a secular Jew.
Very Israeli coming in.
My main affiliation with the JCC.
I just had a great conversation
with Zack Bodner.
And I told him that I love the JCC
because I get to go and listen
to Israeli artists who come here.
But I don't really go to synagogue
and I see Judaism more
in the traditional aspect of it.
And I feel that that's a part of
the disparity between
American-Jews and Israelis.
Do you feel that same way?
Or do you see it differently?
Well, so there is a disparity like that.
One thing that I find, though,
is that for a lot of Israelis
that come here and decide to try
to at least investigate Judaism,
it's their first foray into something
that's very very rich.
And people get very excited.
So, there were a lot of Israelis
that actually have started
trying to study Talmud
and trying to study the Torah.
And really figure out what is it
that defines Judaism
beyond the nationalism.
That they're definitely familiar with.
And which is ironic because
they're coming from Israel
and now they're coming to the Gola
and all of a sudden
they're becoming more Jewish.
That's right. That's right.
And they're definitely becoming
more knowledgeable about being Jew.
Right.
That, for sure is happening here.
And in a place like Silicon Valley,
people are highly intellectual,
highly curious and very motivated.
So, if they spend even just a little bit
of their energy in trying to explore
something Jewish, it ends up being
a very productive experience for them.
Okay. Joey, what is Jewish studies?
I've never went to a Jewish day school.
I've never studied the Talmud.
So, give me a very brief,
what is Jewish studies overall?
Okay. Jewish Studies is a study for us
at the Jewish Study Network.
It's primarily a look
at the classic texts.
It sort of defined the Jewish people.
So, the Torah is the first
and it's the most obvious.
But if you go beyond the Torah
and the rest of Tanakh,
there is a whole wealth of literature
that we have managed to produce
over the past couple of millennia,
dealing with all sorts of things.
So, the Talmud, the Babylonian Tom,
what I would say is first and foremost,
it's almost like a time capsule
in which all of Judaism has been preserved
by the sages a couple thousand years ago.
And it deals with everything from law.
Law is certainly a big part of it.
Jewish law in particular.
But there's also a perspective on things
that people would find cultural.
There are recipes.
There are language conversations.
There is this really the experience
of what it means to be
part of this people.
The Jewish people are particularly
difficult to define.
Because it's hard to define them
as a nation because they live
for thousands of years without a state.
It's also hard to define them
as a religion.
Because people who are not religious
are still considered to be completely part
of the Jewish people, right?
There are people who don't believe in God,
and yet they're as Jewish as somebody
who does believe in God
as long as they follow other criteria.
So, it's almost like this anomaly
of a people that exists on the planet
that has been through
an incredible incredible history
and that has contributed to the world
in so many different ways.
in terms of a sense of
not just the morality and the ethics
that we say come from the Torah.
But even contributing in terms of science
and the understanding
of the way the world operates.
For me, it's not an accident
that there are so many Nobel Prize winners
that happen to come from
the Jewish people.
They're driven.
They're motivated.
And I think that there's just,
when it comes to something Judaism,
there is so much there.
When people come to me and they say
that they want us to try to understand.
So, I usually direct them towards a class
in the Torah portion.
Let them at least see
what it what it's like beyond
the Bible stories that they learned
when they were very little.
Or I'll send them to something like
Ethics of the Fathers
Pirkei Avot,
where they get to understand
the moral underpinnings of what it means
to be a society based around morality.
And I think that all of the things
that people study,
they usually walk away saying
that this informs their current life
Because one thing
that we believe very strongly is,
a human nature hasn't changed
over thousands of years.
We might have new technology
and we might look a little bit different
in terms of the way that we dress.
But the way that we are intrinsically
is still the same.
And so, the sages in their wisdom
managed to articulate values
and principles that are as relevant today
as they were thousands of years ago.
Right. I mean, one of the things
that I discovered here,
especially at Stanford is that
it's not only Jews that do Jewish studies.
But a lot of these things
are relevant also
for the average global citizen.
That the lessons learned about
the community and culture and respect,
they are cross-religion
and they're cross-borders.
Is that something that you also find?
Or do you think, contrary to that,
it is mainly for Jewish people?
No, I would say like this.
I think that there is so much
of it that should be universal.
And the way that we approach
it is universal. Right?
We believe that there's a plan
for the whole world.
It's not just a plan
for the Jewish people.
We just believe that
when it comes to certain laws
that we as the Jewish people,
have a higher level of responsibility
to follow particular laws.
In other words,
we're supposed to be a little bit distinct
and the expression: light into the nations.
We're supposed to be an example
of what it means to live
in a moral and ethical life.
In all of our classes,
I think there are people
that are not Jewish that come
to experience and to learn and to gain.
And I think that when it comes
to a sense of ethics and morality,
yeah, Judaism is the form the law
of the conversations that take place
both in medicine and in law
and all sorts of other arenas.
In fact, organizations like
the Jewish Study Network
are asked to give continuing
education credits in the field of ethics
for all sorts of professional fields
because there is value that's universal.
Wow. So, where are we headed now?
So, I mean, one of the key things
that I've observed in Israel is definitely
a very clear separation
and a growing separation, unfortunately,
between secular Jews and religious Jews.
I haven't yet experienced this here.
But, coming in from your perspective
of Jewish studies and trying to bring
together these two tribes
here in Silicon Valley
and looking more globally the world,
where are the Jewish people headed?
And what is our role in helping
make sure that it's headed the right way?
That's a very good question.
I think that it's true that the media
likes to report on the flashpoints
of conflict between
the religious community
and secular community.
I think in reality, that the communities
are starting to understand each other
a little differently.
So, for example,
within the ultra religious in Israel,
there is a big shift in which people
are deciding to embrace secular education
in a way that they haven't before.
I'm sure you're familiar with Kama-Tech.
I was just about to talk about
Moshe Friedman because I love him to bits
and he's incredible. Yeah.
Yeah, he is incredible.
And what he's doing is amazing.
And it's just a tip of the iceberg.
There are many people that are starting
to realize that that community
can't continue to exist
at the levels of poverty
that they've been living at.
And that they have to embrace
some sense of modernity when it comes
to providing for themselves.
And they're doing so.
And the media doesn't like
to talk about it as much.
It's not as exciting as the war
as they go on between the communities.
They do believe that
there's a very big shift.
I think that I am a little concerned
with the relationship between
Israel and the diaspora.
I think that the Jewish community
in the diaspora
is not as in touch with the centrality
that Israel should play within Judaism.
Right.
So, they see it as something
other than themselves.
It's the Jewish homeland.
But they don't necessarily feel
as connected to it as they should.
And I think that it's the responsibility
of the community here
to take a look at the way that
we're educating our young people, right?
The ones that do get a Jewish education,
why are they not walking away
with a passion for Israel?
I think that that is a failing
that has to be addressed.
Definitely. I'm very involved
with the Birthright program.
And I also have Gidi Mark,
the CEO of Birthright on this show,
and I did a few of those trips, myself.
And what I find is that,
the minute you have somebody
walk into Israel and see the miracle
of the Holy Land and the startup nation
part of it as well.
I think that one of the most important
things that we can do for Israel is,
put aside some of the conflicts
and the politics and the religion.
Just talk about the miracle
of the startup nation
and what incredible things
that it has done.
And I see how eye opening it is for people
who read the book Start Up Nation
for the first time.
And they really understand that, Wow.
Like a nation of now Nine million people
in this heart of conflict is able
to produce such magnificent work.
I think that's a major major part.
And obviously,
the Jewish studies is important.
But I also think that combining that
with the intellect and combining that
with the successes,
I think that's incredible.
Right. I think so, also.
The trick is trying to figure out
how to convince that
the American Jewish community
that they should get what we call
the nakhat from the startup nation.
What is that? The what?
Nakhat.
Oh, nakhat. Yeah. Yeah.
That they should feel
that it's theirs also, right?
I think that's the key that's missing.
So, it's wonderful to read about
The Startup Nation,
but if you feel that it's not you,
then you're just reading
about somebody else's success,
which might be inspiring.
But if the Jewish community can embrace
the notion that that is who they are.
In other words,
the people living in Israel are part
and parcel with the Jewish people.
And it's one body.
And therefore, they should feel
that it's their success.
I think that's something
that we're trying to achieve.
Is there a worry
that within this centrality
and pulling together as one body,
that the Jewish people
can start alienating
or continue alienating others
around the world who then view
the Jewish people as
this closed group, closed minded?
Is that a worry that we have?
Or do you not think that's the case?
I personally don't worry
so much about that.
I think that if you look at Jewish history
over the span of the thousands of years,
for most people, they weren't interested
in us integrating into them, right?
That was never a desire per se.
And in terms of today,
where people are willing
to allow us to integrate.
I think that people
have a certain element of respect,
as long as we're prepared to share.
Meaning, if we were isolated
to the point that we develop technology
that we weren't exporting
to the rest of the world,
then that would be a problem.
Or if we had morality and ethics
that we weren't prepared to share
with the rest of the world,
that would also be a problem.
But the stronger that we become
as a people, the more influence
we can have on others for the positive.
And I think that that's something
that they would also embrace.
Okay. Okay. That's fascinating.
So, Rabbi, we just have
a few minutes left.
But I'd love to get to know,
what is your favorite teaching?
The thing that you enjoy most teaching,
whether that's at Stanford
or through the JSN.
Like your number one classroom idea.
That's a great question.
I love teaching the Torah.
And specifically, there is one section
in the book of Devarim of Deuteronomy.
I'd love to learn.
About the Va'etchanan,
Okay.
And if someone were to ask me,
"Rabbi, if I can only come to one
of your classes one week of the year,
which should I come to?
I would tell you to come
to that particular class.
And the reason is because
it contains all the fundamentals
of Judaism pretty much in one place.
Okay. So, give me in one minute thing.
What is the fundamental
according to you with that?
So, I think the fundamentals are that
there is a God who created the world
and he demands a level of morality
and obedience from us.
That we believe that
he took us out of Egypt,
not so that we would be free of anything,
but that we would become slaves to Him.
Meaning, that we would live our lives
with a sense of purpose.
And that God created the world
And our job is to help
fulfill that mission.
That's some of what you can get
from that parsha.
And do you find that
that is sometimes also
could potentially alienate people
who are Jews but don't come
from that background?
Who might come in and say,
"As a secular Jew, I'm hearing like,
Wow. Be slave to God and go
with the purpose of fulfilling his mission."
So, how do you balance that with
trying to bring in Israelis
and helping them understand Judaism better
and be more fond of it?
So, I'll tell you the truth.
I think the more that people study,
including secular Israelis,
and there are a lot of secular Israelis
that I study with.
The more they start to realize
that there is a lot of brilliance
and there's a lot of wisdom,
and they start to realize that
there's a system that is incredible,
that is incredibly progressive,
that doesn't fit anyone's
preconceived notions when it comes
to all sorts of issues.
I think, unfortunately,
Judaism is a bit of a victim
of being slapped together
with other world religions.
And, so people are familiar
with other religions.
They assume the same applies to Judaism
and they don't realize that there is
a different take on all sorts of,
really all sorts of issues.
Everything from women's issues,
to financial issues,
to the issues of
how to structure an economy, right?
The fact that Judaism is capitalistic
and yet it has a way of
defending capitalism
so that it supports everybody, right?
It's a very intricate structure.
The more people spend time studying that,
the more they start to realize
that there is a lot of value in it.
Interesting.
So, what I would say is I would encourage
people like yourself
to just take a little time
and investigate.
And I think you'll be pleasantly surprised
that it's something
that you'll find meaningful
and it will help inform the way
that you interact with people.
For many people, they find
that it helps with their marriage.
It helps them as parents.
It helps with the way that they
interact with their community.
And people feel that there is
a more meaningful purpose for life.
Right. And I definitely,
the number one thing
that I take from this is also
this idea of open mindedness.
And I'm definitely holding myself
to be open minded and learning anything
and everything that I can.
And I think one of the issues
with religion in general is that
people come with preconceived notions
or little soundbites.
They come up with conclusions
and then they have their belief
with those conclusions.
And I think that this investigation
is something that we all owe to ourselves.
By the way, not just necessarily
through Judaism.
I would love to also investigate
the Koran a little bit
and investigate Christianity
and understand the world
a little bit better.
And I think actually, that's one
of the key aspects of empathizing
and solving a lot of these conflicts
that we have is being able
to understand each other better.
Rabbi Joey, right before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
This is the most modern question
and probably the most difficult question.
100%
So, I would say that I'm Passionate.
Yes.
I would also say that
I consider myself to be God-Fearing.
Okay. What does that mean?
Meaning that I try to live
with a consciousness of the higher power
that we call God.
That's aware of what it is
that I'm doing.
It helps me do the right thing,
even though sometimes
I'd be tempted to do things
that are not necessarily right.
Okay.
And I think the third is,
I would say that I try to be
incredibly Open and Creative.
I love that.
Rabbi Joey, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
Thank you, Michael.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Okay. You too.
Bye bye.
Bye.